five four three two one hi I'm commander
Chris Hadfield astronaut spaceship
commander space Walker part-time
musician I'm here today to hopefully
debunk some common space myths here's
this common perception that you will
immediately fry to a crisp by the
unfiltered unadulterated solar radiation
if you get sucked out of the airlock in
truth it's way worse than that in the
shade in space it's like minus 250
degrees but the part of you that's in
the Sun it's plus 250 degrees at least
so it's gonna start boiling and burning
so it's like lying on a red-hot stove
with a piece of dry ice on your back and
your lungs are gonna be sucked flat
instantaneously but even worse than that
is your blood is gonna boil like opening
a can of pop where suddenly that all the
little bubbles come out because there's
no air pressure around you so
simultaneously you are going to freeze
boil burn get the bends and no longer be
able to breathe not a good way to go
I've done two spacewalks and I was very
thankful to have a spacesuit around my
body so that none of those things that
happen to me
[Music]
sometimes you hear that you have to work
out constantly or you will pass out and
possibly die in space not true living on
a spaceship is the most lazy existence
you can imagine you're weightless you do
not have to lift a finger you don't have
to hold your head up your heart doesn't
have to lift your blood against gravity
you can be the laziest person in the
universe in space but eventually you
need to come back to earth and if you
don't exercise for your whole 6 months
in space you're sort of turn into a
jellyfish so we do exercise two hours a
day on a spaceship we have a resistive
machine we have a unicycle and we have a
treadmill where elastics hold us down
just to keep our bodies strong enough
and our bones dense enough so when we
get home we don't just fall over like a
pole but you don't need to work out
you've probably heard that space has a
smell maybe like burnt steak or some
type of barbecue that's true when you
come in from a spacewalk you're
surrounded by the emptiness of space
it's sort of like the opposite of air
there's nothing there at all when you
quickly repressurize the hatch and you
open up the hatch and you smell what is
that lingering smell from a place that
used to be exposed to space but smell in
there is a little bit like that trace of
a smell of gunpowder or a burnt steak or
to me it's sort of like brimstone like a
which has just been there it's a cool
lingering trace of a smell I think what
it really is is the emptiness of space
the vacuum of space is actually pulling
trace chemicals out of the metal of the
walls of the ship little bits of stuff
you never smell because normally there's
air pressure holding them into the metal
they're slowly off gassing those tiny
little trace gasses and trace particles
that otherwise they never get into your
nose and those are released sort of that
metallic gunpowder fired smell that's
where the smell is coming from maybe
it's not even coming from space it's
just sort of coming from spaces effect
on our ship yeah in truth smells a
little bit like a burnt steak
so there's a lot of word out there that
if you go incredibly fast like the speed
of light if you could travel at the
speed of light that you won't age and
despite thousands of years going by
you'll stay the same but everybody that
you know will die that's not really true
Einstein called it relativity because
what he meant was your aging will be
different relative to people's aging on
earth
you'll still age time will still pass
for you but people on earth will age at
a different rate so that if you came
back after going incredibly fast you
would have gotten older by the amount of
time that it took for you to travel but
people on earth would have aged much
much faster they would have had a longer
period of time because even get going
fast enough your speed is sort of
proportional to the time passing so
you'll still age but you just ain't a
different rate than people back on earth
Einstein did this cool thought
experiment imagine if you were looking
at a clock that the light from the clock
is coming and hitting your eyeballs and
telling you it's 12 o'clock I'll imagine
if you could move away from that clock
at the speed of light it would only say
12 o'clock because that light and you
would be moving away from the clock at
the same speed so for you it would look
like it was always 12 o'clock forever
you'd still be getting older but that
clock would always look like it was the
same time the people on earth were
continuing to live they're not aware of
you go on the speed of light so you can
see that the time for you because of
your speed is relatively different than
the time for the people on earth it's a
really unusual thing to try and grasp in
your head what happens when something
blows up in space if something explodes
in space will it make a sound and could
a human hear it it's a pretty easy
question to answer the Sun is just an
explosion the Sun is the biggest
explosion any of us can imagine it's a
huge continuous thermonuclear explosions
every atom bomb we've ever built way
more than that continuously exploding it
would be the loudest thing imaginable
it's constantly happening but we don't
hear a whisper of it and that's because
there's nothing to carry the sound from
the Sun to us even though it's
incredibly violent there's nowhere for
the pressure of all of that sound all of
that noise to be carried across the
emptiness of space to shake my eardrum
in
and let me hear the sound of the Sun
it's a good thing it'd be deafening so
if something explodes in space it makes
sound but there's no way for that sound
to be carried across space so that I
could hear there is this idea out there
that maybe the only way that we could
really create gravity is to spin the
spaceship so that everybody is stuck to
the sides like one of those rides at the
fair where you're pinned against the
wall and for now that's actually true we
don't know how to control gravity we
have no way to control gravity we can
sort of pretend there's gravity by
spinning a ship and everything stick to
the sides like a ball on the end of a
string maybe someday we'll figure out
how to control gravity but for now we
have to spin the whole ship only in the
middle would they be weightless I've
seen that people think that NASA is
working on warp speed so that we can
travel at the speed of light to
interstellar planets warp speed is an
invention of science fiction if we knew
how to work on warp speed we would we
don't know how to go anywhere near the
speed of light it takes an unlimited
amount of energy the faster you go the
more energy it takes a equals MC squared
it goes up with the square of the speed
in fact so how can you generate that
much electricity and what does it do to
your mast we don't know we think maybe
it's possible that you could go faster
than the speed of light but we sure
don't understand how right now so we're
not really working on it so it's not
really true we're hoping for
in so many movies you see that the only
way that they survive interstellar
travel from one star to another is to
freeze yourself into cryo sleep we don't
know how to do that right now when you
freeze water which is what we're mostly
made of our blood and everything it goes
into crystals it turns into ice crystals
and if you allow the beautiful delicate
nature of your human body to expand into
ice crystals it'll destroy the structure
of you it'll kill you you know frostbite
destroys it so that you get gangrene in
your hand you'd end up with entirely
destroyed body so right now we do not
know how to successfully freeze a human
body so that it is not going to be
permanently destroyed maybe we'll figure
it out someday but all of those movies
that rely on freezing the crew we don't
know how to do that it's not real you
see on the internet all the time someone
has built a balloon and they've launched
some little figurine with a camera
attached to it where they take a picture
way up high in the atmosphere you can
see the curvature of the earth it's
pretty cool but there's some people
thinking you could fly yourself all the
way up to the stratosphere with some
sort of high-altitude balloon you can
actually but it's really complicated
Felix Baumgartner when he did his his
leap out of a balloon and actually go
through the speed of sound falling down
towards the Earth and landing with a
parachute he was way up into the
stratosphere the stratosphere starts at
about six or seven miles up it's not all
that high then that goes on for a long
way there's not enough air to breathe
you kind of need to have an airliner
with the pressure inside to keep your
body healthy if you're that high but if
you take the right equipment with you
yes we can use a balloon to lift us high
enough to get all the way up into the
stratosphere so if you have the right
equipment it's true
you've probably read somewhere on the
internet that if you go to the Space
Station your body will get taller sort
of expand and it'll be painful and
you're gonna be taller forever an
irreversible experience and it's not
really true as I'm standing here talking
right now gravity is pushing me down
towards the floor every single bone in
my body and a little bit of gristle
that's in between the bones like each of
the vertebra of my back everyone has a
little disk in between each of the bones
and even my hip bones on my knee bones
there's a little bit of a gap well if
there's no gravity pushing me down and
those gaps can all get a tiny bit bigger
if you stay in weightlessness for a few
weeks in fact your body just sort of
stretches because the gap between each
of the bones gets a little bigger and in
my case I got about that much taller but
you aren't really taller you're just
sort of temporarily longer but it's not
permanent as soon as you get home and
gravity starts doing its its work on you
and grinding you down everything
squishes back down to its launch so you
maybe for a little while a little bit
taller in space and it may hurt your
back a little cuz everything's sort of
getting pulled tight some people have
back pain in space as a result but it's
not really growing it's just sort of
stretching to your natural maximum that
you're gonna get squished back again as
soon as you get home if you do get maybe
that much longer after you've been in
space for a few weeks
think what your pants would be like
you're you know they're gonna they're
gonna be high above your ankle and if
you put on a spacesuit who custom-fit
the spacesuit to the size of your body
but we know it's going to happen so we
actually plan in advance we fit our
spacesuits knowing that the astronauts
are gonna be a little bit taller when
they're in space or at least their
bodies are gonna be a little bit
stretched and even the seat that
protects us when we come back to earth
the crash seat so that when we hit the
ground it protects us properly we allow
for the fact that our back bones are
gonna be slightly longer when we're up
there but your clothes you don't really
know how they fit because you're
floating around weightless your shirt is
always floating around your body so you
never really have a sense up there how
well your clothes fit just because
there's no gravity to pull them down and
look and see how well they're fitting on
your body it's more like they're just
floating next
I've read somewhere that onboard the
International Space Station bacteria
multiplies ten times faster in space so
if you get sick your body is gonna be
like torn apart by this ravenous strain
of mutant Salmonella now it is a
different place than Earth the space
station we run around with little swabs
all the time to measure what microbes
and what viruses and what little tiny
bits of life might be growing on the
spaceship we also go around with little
cleaners and wet wipes and wipe down the
whole space station all the time like in
a hospital to try and keep the whole
thing clean and hygienic and we are
finding that some of those primitive
forms of life do mutate slightly
differently in the high radiation
weightless environment of the spaceship
but no one has died yet because of the
mutant Salmonella I'm Chris Hadfield
hopefully this has helped answer some of
those comments basements